[Musique]
où
oh
elle assume et prési les caprices du
sort regardez ce en horreur les horreurs
de la mort affermir un grand trône et le
quitter sans peine et pour tout dire
enfin vivre et mourir en reine ainsi
parle la fin de lettre madeleine de
scudéry d'anne d'autriche n'est espagnol
mariée à 14 ans au futur louis xiii pour
resserrer les liens entre pour bon et
habsburg reine de france délaissés et
calomnié devenue une région brillante
pendant la minorité de son fils louis
xiv louis xiv
je crois qu'il est plus que permis de le
dire doit beaucoup à sa mère anne
d'autriche et veut dire un mot
d'aujourd'hui patriotisme d'anne
d'autriche à l'égard de la france
devenue son pays en pleine guerre de
trente ans brisant toutes les
oppositions des grands du royaume
deux étrangers une espagnole anne
d'autriche et un italien
mazarin vont habilement gouverner la
france pendant près de 18 ans grâce à
leurs efforts le roi soleil hérite d'un
état fort et consolidées dans lequel son
absolutisme va s'exprimer pleinement à
quelqu'un qui disait louis xiv
ce fut une grande reine son fils répondu
non ce fut un grand roi par cette phrase
on voit bien le côté politique d'anne
d'autriche
[Musique]
au soir des guerres de religion qui
enseignait la france henri iv premier
roi bourbon qui a tant oeuvré à la
pacification du royaume est assassinée
dans son carrosse par le fanatique
françois ravaillac le 14 mai ses 110
à la suite de cet assassinat un conseil
de régence avait été instituée mais le
testament de henri iv a été annulée et
la régence a été prise totalement en
main par sa veuve marie de médicis alors
marie de médicis naturellement n'est pas
la reine de france en exercice puisque
le souverain ne peut être qu'un homme en
france et ce souverain c'est
nécessairement le fils aîné de henri iv
qui prend le titre de louis xiii
mais louis xiii au monde la mort de son
père à seulement de l'avant donc en le
proclame roi
et puis c'est donc le conseil de régence
qui va gouverner à sa place et ce
conseil de régence se réduit à sa mère
marie de médicis mme marie de médicis
s'est vu donner une mission par le pape
qui était en somme ma chère princesse
épousé le roi de france fait lui
beaucoup d'enfants bon catholique
la régente valeur à l'encontre de la
politique de son défunt mari ait fait le
choix de se rapprocher des habsbourgs
l'autre grande puissance catholique
européenne tout son programme politique
c'est de pouvoir amarrer la france au
catholicisme et elle va s'y employer
voilà alors c'est ça la toile de fond de
ce qui se passe en 1615 c'est à dire la
réalisation de ce qui est le grand rêve
de marie de médicis probablement bien
avant qu'elle devienne régente mais à
partir du moment où elles et régente
elle a en tout cas sur le papier tous
les pouvoirs et ce grand rêve c'est ce
que on appellera à l'époque déjà le
double mariage espagnol
le 28 novembre 16 115 louis xiii épouse
anne d'autriche fille du roi d'espagne
philippe iii et arrière petite fille de
l'empereur charles quint
alors que sa soeur élisabeth de france
épouse le frère dan qu'il deviendra
philippe 4 ans et 121 en accédant au
trône d'espagne
il s'agissait d'éviter à nouveau une
guerre contre l'espagne c'était un
mariage très politique
le mariage de louis xiii s'explique par
part par un traité qui a été qui a été
signé au mois d'août 1612 avec l'espagne
et donc lui 13 est obligé de se marier
contre son gré et d'ailleurs en novembre
louis accompli son devoir le mariage est
consommé
mais cette première expérience forcé de
traumatise au point qu'il craindra
d'avoir d'autres rapports intimes
après cette nuit de noce désastreuse
il délaisse son épouse et évitera de
rester seul avec elle louis xiii n'est
pas quelqu'un de sensuel et de physique
et naturellement la pauvre anne
d'autriche s'ennuiera mortellement
héritière de la puissante maison de
habsbourg perçu comme l'ennemi
héréditaire de la france un d'autriche
et sans cesse raillé par sa belle mère
marie de médicis la petite reine
cristallise la fois la méfiance du
peuple et l'indifférence de son dépôt
c'est un homme qui n'aime pas les femmes
face et ça c'est tout à fait clair c'est
un homme qui a du mal à avoir une
relation avec une femme et c'est un
homme qui va aussi mettre de son
caractère dans ses relations avec les
hommes il se plaît beaucoup plus à à
être avec des secours la planète et
compagnon du compagnon de chasse il
était beaucoup plus à l'aise n'avait
plus honte de bégayer alors qu'il était
assez mal à l'aise avec les femmes
on parle souvent la misogynie de de
louis xiii ou très régulièrement il
essayé d'écarter les femmes de soi de
versailles plus tard soit de différentes
parties de chasse qui pouvait faire et
il a toujours été lié à plusieurs
favoris ça a été lui même ça a été trois
rats ça a été ça marc saint simon le
père du mémorialiste et il a toujours
besoin certainement d'avoir un mentor
pour avancer soigneusement tenus à
distance des affaires du royaume par
marie de médicis essai ambitieux favori
concino concini et la galigaï la
préoccupation première de louis xiii
devient très vite son devoir de monarque
conseillé par son fidèle fauconnier le
duc charles de luynes leroy entend
bientôt assumer pleinement ses fonctions
[Musique]
louis qu'on va surnommé le juste prend
le pouvoir à bras le corps ses partisans
fomente un assassinat le 24 avril et 16
117 qu'on finit devenue maréchale
tombent dans une embuscade en arrivant
au louvre et il est poignardée à mort
les juges du parlement de paris accuse
son épouse la galigaï de sorcellerie et
la condamne à être décapité après ce
coup de force
la reine mère est obligé de s'exiler au
château de blois
et
c'était pas un modèle d'amour conjugal
il avait d'autres soucis d'autres
préoccupations il était très tourné vers
son maintien au pouvoir
après avoir conseillé et soutenu louis
xiii dans sa prise de pouvoir
le duc de luynes aide également le roi a
trouvé le bonheur dans son mariage il
pousse littéralement le jeune homme dans
le lit de son épouse et enferme à double
tour les deux tourtereaux la cour espère
voir bientôt naître des enfants royaux
[Musique]
mais en 722 leroy apprend que son épouse
vient de faire une deuxième fausse
couche elle a fait une chute alors
qu'elle traversait le louvre en courant
avec une de ses dames de compagnie alors
la première fois nous 13
il n'a même pas à pardonner il est
complètement épouvanté désespéré désolé
il espère que sa femme va bien et tout
et tout et il est rassuré quand elle se
retrouve enceinte quelques temps après
la deuxième fausse couche
ça lui a pas plu du tout parce qu'on
avait conseillé la prudence à l'autriche
alors ça ne lui a pas plu il a tenu pour
responsable surtout la principale copil
dame de compagnie d'anne d'autriche qui
s'est dépêché de faire exister de l'aco
mais enfin le mal était fait mais
surtout il s'est mis dans la tête que sa
femme s'était un peu une écervelée
la relation va être restera toujours
très difficile jusqu'à la fin il n'y
aura pas de rapports rapprochés entre
louis xiii et sa femme à la fois avec
cet aspect physique qui atteint lui 13
ils n'aiment pas les femmes ne veut pas
en entendre parler il fait les enfants
parce qu'il faut les faire parce que
c'est son devoir mais ça ne devait pas
être une mince partie de plaisir entre
entre louis xiii et sa femme anne
d'autriche se sentait toujours comme
espagnol d'abord et plus louis xiii lui
faisait on va dire un peu la tête et
plus et se rejetaient vers sa famille
espagnole vers son frère le roi
d'espagne
il y avait des dames de compagnie qui
était française mais il y en avait
d'autres qui étaient espagnols et elle
prenait un tout petit peu partie dans
les relations franco espagnoles en se
lamentant si on peut dire des attitudes
de la politique française qui était pas
toujours aligné à 100% sur celle de
l'espagne même si à cette époque les
relations sont effectivement très
étroite très confiante et vont dans le
même sens mais de temps en temps il ya
des intérêts opposés
l'absence d'héritier fragilise la
dynastie et encourage les conspirations
en 16 125 lorsque la reine anne
d'autriche accompagne sa belle soeur
henriette promise au roi d'angleterre
charles 1er elle subit une courée honte
et de la part du duc de buckingham qui
provoque la colère de louis xiii avec si
l'on peut dire la complicité de
richelieu qui est en quelque sorte son
bras armé il va réduire à l'obéissance
les nobles et le premier d'entre eux
c'est son frère gaston d'orléans agents
de toutes les conspirations du règne
mais le roi ne va jamais faiblir va
déployer une autorité sans faille
le cardinal de richelieu créatures de
marie de médicis a su gagner la
confiance de louis xiii nommé grand
aumônier auprès d'anne d'autriche en 16
115 il est propulsé principal ministre
hans hess 124 cette nomination marque le
début d'une politique inflexible visant
à rétablir la pleine autorité du roi qui
doit être le garant de l'unité de l'état
c'est un homme d'église il est très
favorable dans les premières années à
l'espagne et puis petit à petit il
évolue et dans les années qui suivent
après 1625 est toujours prêt proche des
espagnols mais il marque petit à petit
sa différence richelieu fixe le cap de
la centralisation en réformant les
institutions
il prend des mesures radicales afin de
soumettre la noblesse indocile de briser
le pouvoir politique des huguenots et
d'affaiblir la maison rivale d'autriche
mais c'est ambitieux programme fait du
cardinal l'homme à battre
il s'emploie alors à déjouer les
conspirations étant de museler le frère
du roi
gaston d'orléans qui se verrait bien
porter la couronne de france
ces complots une particularité c'est que
chaque fois qu'il était éventé gaston
d'orléans s'en confesser et donner au
sens policiers du terme donner les noms
des comploteurs qui avait
comploté avec lui donc c'était un drôle
de personnage ambitieux certes peut-être
pas très courageux et surtout pas très
malin puisque aucun de ces complots
contre son frère n'est venu à ses fins
richelieu s'appuie sur le chancelier
pierre séguin véritable mains de la
justice ils oeuvrent à la centralisation
du pouvoir monarchique et instruit les
procès des conspirateurs
le cardinal est également grand mécène
ils font de l'académie française en 16
135 protège nombre d'artistes et possède
une grande collection d'oeuvres d'art
[Musique]
si le fameux édit de nantes met fin aux
guerres de religion et pacifier les
tensions entre les deux factions louis
xiii craint pourtant de voir grandir un
véritable état protestants qui
menacerait l'unité de son royaume
catholique avec l'aide du cardinal de
richelieu
il s'emploie donc à réduire les
prérogatives des huguenots en 16 128
il reprend la place de sûretés
protestant de la rochelle au terme d'un
siège particulièrement éprouvant de près
d'une année
alors que la rochelle étaient réputés
comme quasiment imprenable
ce siège de la rochelle pour beaucoup de
catholiques c'est un moment décisif et
c'est le signal de l'extermination la
conversion en masse de tous les
protestants or que font louis xiii et
richelieu quelques mois encore de
campagne militaire après le siège de la
rochelle
et puis ensuite le roi dit ben
maintenant c'est terminé allez on fait
la paix on rogne un peu sur les
privilèges politiques et militaires des
protestants et nous avons mieux à faire
maintenant et c'est nous occuper de
l'indépendance de la france
indépendance c'est transparent ça veut
dire vis-à-vis de l'espagne
depuis que louis xiii règne sur la
france les habsbourg d'espagne et
d'autriche ont considérablement agrandi
leur territoire en 16 118 lorsque les
habsbourg d'autriche s'engage dans un
combat contre les princes protestants
allemands qu'on appellera plus tard la
guerre de trente ans louis c'est que
leur succès éventuel risque d'accroître
leur hégémonie
il craint à juste titre l'encerclement
de la france est alors qu il combat les
huguenots dans son royaume
paradoxalement ils décident soutenir
secrètement les ita protestants
allemands puis 13 endosse la politique
préconisée par richelieu et petit à
petit on s'écarte progressivement de
l'espagne et dans les années 1600 29
1630 on ne se fait pas ouvertement la
guerre mais on est dans des camps
opposés richelieu bras armé de louis
xiii subventionnant secret les princes
protestants néerlandais et suédois et
demi des habsbourgs
d'autre part l'espagne qu'on voit des
territoires du nord de l'italie
cette région est un élément stratégique
majeur dans l'équilibré des pouvoirs en
europe
elle sert de lien entre lee hasbourg
d'autriche et les habsbourg d'espagne
si les armées impériales parvenait à
s'emparer du nord de l'italie
l'existence même de la france serait
menacée puisque elle se retrouverait
encerclé par des territoires ennemis on
va développer de plus en plus un jeu de
bascule qui fait que la france va aider
en sous main mais c'est très visible
quand on donne de l'argent aux cantons
motoriste des militaires français à les
combattre à titre de volontaires mais
ton volontaire entre guillemets dans les
armées du roi de danemark du roi de
suède ou d'un certain nombre d'autres
princes qui sont des princes protestants
qui sont en guerre contre la famille de
hatschbourg c'est bien clair qu'on n'est
pas dans le même camp
mais problème politique de la deuxième
moitié du règne de louis xiii trouvent
leurs racines dans les guerres
extérieures et la recherche de fonds
pour les financer en 16 135 louis xiii
déclare officiellement la guerre au
frère de son épouse philippe iv
d'espagne
l'entrée de la france en guerre se
manifeste pour le royaume par une
augmentation absolument un fabuleuse des
impôts jamais on n'avait vu une
augmentation de ce type et il faut bien
voir que face à l'espagne la situation
de la france est totalement différente
l'espagne elle tire ses ressources de
l'or et de l'argent de ses colonies la
france tire ses ressources des impôts
qu'elles prélèvent sur ces populations
alors bien sûr la france et plus peuplé
est un royaume riche mais il y a une
limite et cette limite
elle va se manifester pendant que la
france va être en guerre à l'extérieur
elle va aussi être en guerre à
l'intérieur puisque les populations vont
se révolter contre ce tour de vis fiscal
qui leur est insupportable
la taille prélèvements obligatoires
depuis la guerre de cent ans frappe
surtout les paysans la population
s'oppose violemment à la guerre et le
vague de révoltes rend impossible la
collecte de l'impôt
[Musique]
pour dissimuler le fait que la france
est partie en guerre contre d'autres
monarques catholique louis xiii fait le
geste religieux le plus symbolique de
son règne il place le royaume de france
sous la protection de la vierge et
instaure les procession du 15 août
durant lesquelles ces sujets doivent
prier dieu et la vierge pour les heureux
succès du roi
marie de médicis qui désapprouvent la
politique de louis xiii et de son
inflexible le ministre se réfugie chez
sa fille dans les pays bas espagnols
marie de médicis s'insurge contre
l'évolution de la politique française
elle n'est pas seule il ya beaucoup de
catholiques obscures ou puissants qu'ils
aident mais à partir de cet exil
volontaire exil de la france
elle mène une campagne forcenée contre
richelieu
c'est à dire aussi contre louis xiii et
en finançant des complots en finançant
des campagnes de presse etc
et elle ne reviendra jamais en france
dans ce conflit entre marie de médicis
et louis xiii que choisit anne
d'autriche et bâle choisi le parti de
marie de médicis
alors la situation est telle que louis
xiii ne veut plus la voir ne veut plus à
fréquenter et qu'il faut vraiment les
admonestations de richelieu qui lui dit
écoutez vous continuez comme ça vous ne
perdez tout espoir de jamais avoir à
l'enfant et c'est gaston d'orléans votre
frère cadet que vous méprisez que vous
haïssez qui est une espèce de chiffe
molle constantin consistante et c'est
lui qui va boucher excédé la guerre
contre l'espagne sa patrie de naissance
anéanti tout espoir pour un d'autriche
de se voir confier des responsabilités
politiques
aux yeux de ces sujets la reine incarne
plus que jamais l'ennemi à combattre
alors n2 triche est placé entre deux
puisqu'elle est espagnol et un
d'autriche a été d'autant plus ennuyé
par cette guerre qu on la soupçonnait
d'être une espionne ce qui était presque
inévitable
c'était une oeuvre bourgue elle à la
cour de france
la mésentente au sein du couple royal
s'aggrave encore davantage quand anne
d'autriche prend parti contre richelieu
à cause de la correspondance secrète
qu'elle entretient avec son frère
philippe iv d'espagne
la reine est même suspecté
d'intelligence avec l'ennemi
elle va très régulièrement au couvent du
val-de-grâce qu'elle a contribué à
fonder et on s'aperçoit qu'elle utilise
ses séjours au couvent du val de grâce
pour correspondre de façon clandestine
donc il dit si tu avec madrid
alors elle sait pas grand chose si vous
voulez des secrets de l'état parce qu'on
se méfie tellement d'elle mais enfin
elle donne tout ce qu'elle peut comme
indication richelieu un réseau d'espions
bien fait donc un beau jour il s'en rend
compte
un d'autriche et interrogés par le
chancelier c'est à dire le ministre de
la justice
l'interrogatoire se dérouler un moment
et lui dit veuillez me remettre la
lettre que vous avez dans votre corps
sage
comment je n'ai pas de l'être là
chancelier séguier plonge la main dans
le corsage et en extraire clame alors
pour imagine l'humiliation pour
n'importe qui pourra d'autres et elle
est prise en flagrant délit elle est
obligée de signer des aveux elle est
obligée d'implorer à genoux la pitié le
pardon de louis xiii ont de lui épargna
malgré tout malgré ces brouilles cette
fâcherie 7
cette mésentente politique et cette
mésentente dans l'alcôve et bien au bout
de 23 ans dont on sait qu anne
d'autriche avait déjà fait deux ou trois
fausses couches épaisses de louis xiii
en savoie mais au bout de 23 ans elle va
donner un fils à louis xiii et on sait
que c'est un fils de louis xiii parce
que louis xiii était venu à paris
et puis il ya eu un orage considérable
il était resté passer la nuit au louvre
est et on l'avait retrouvé dans l'alcôve
de la reine et neuf mois plus tard
naissait vraiment un don de dieu et le
prénom de louis xiv porte bien ce signe
de le divin puisque il est baptisé louis
dieudonné
le 5 septembre 638 la naissance du futur
louis xiv apaise le climat délétère de
suspicion cet heureux événement est
suivi deux ans plus tard par une seconde
naissance le 21 septembre 16 140
philippe de france qui très duc
d'orléans voit le jour en donnant deux
héritiers au royaume anne d'autriche
pérennise le trône et consolide sa
position à la cour peu importe les
sentiments qu'elle peut avoir à l'égard
de louis xiii mais elle est devenue la
mère du futur roi de france est donc à
partir de ce moment là le changement que
l'on constate en elle c'est qu'elle est
vraiment devenue reine de france acharné
à défendre la france y compris contre sa
famille espagnole et elle va jouer un
rôle considérable dans la défense du
trône de louis xiv dans la défense des
institutions dans la défense à la fois
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur et vis-à-vis
d'un certain nombre de menaces
intérieures du royaume richelieu tombe
gravement malade et le roi reste à ses
côtés jusqu'à la fin
avant de mourir le 4 décembre 16 140 2
il désigne le cardinal jules mazarin
comme son digne successeur louis xiii
appel mazarin au conseil et fait même de
lui le parrain du dauphin il était né
roturier et c'est son seul titre de
noblesse en quelque sorte ça a été la
pourpre cardinalice c'est le fait
d'avoir été consacré cardinal peut-être
sans avoir jamais été prêtre d'ailleurs
mais c'était l'équivalent d'un titre de
noblesse d'être cardinal et donc c'est
ce qui lui a donné un légitimité pour
intervenir dans les affaires du royaume
il a laissé dans l'histoire de france la
trace d'un homme qui s'était enrichie
impunément qui ne pensaient qu'à sa
fortune mais c'est pas tout à fait exact
il a été amené par richelieu qui avait
quand même détecté en lui des qualités
d'homme d'état de négociateur dans ma
bile il l'a prouvé dans toutes ces vies
[Musique]
de santé fragile et n'ayant aucune
confiance en son épouse espagnol le roi
prend la précaution d'organiser sa
succession
il fait enregistrer par le parlement une
déclaration prévoyant l'entrée de
mazarin et des ministres au conseil de
régence
ainsi les prises de décisions devront
être collégiale réduisant l'influencé de
la reine
[Musique]
le 14 mai 16 143 le jour du 33e
anniversaire de la mort de son père
louis xiii succombe à son tour
il est inhumé dans la nécropole des rois
de france à saint-denis la sépulture du
cardinal de richelieu se trouve quant à
elle dans la chapelle de la sorbonne
[Musique]
louis xiii commencent finalement un peu
le règne de louis xiv
c'est à dire qu'il va il va
véritablement posé les fondations de
l'autorité royale et ses fondations vont
rester des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années
et si l'on peut faire véritablement une
synthèse du règne de louis xiii a été
véritablement de calmer la noblesse
d'asseoir l'autorité royale et surtout
de l'avoir en main mazarin s'emploie à
instruire le dauphin dès son plus jeune
âge il assiste aux réunions du conseil
et reçoit les diplomates étrangers
le cardinal cherche aussi à éveiller
l'intérêt de louis xiv pour les affaires
militaires
il emmène admirer les troupes et
l'initient au jeu de stratégie
[Musique]
louis xiv succède à son père mais là
seulement cinq ans et il ne prend pas en
personne les rênes du pouvoir
un conseil de régence va donc gouverner
la france jusqu'à sa majorité
oui 13 avait institué un conseil de
régence et dès que louis xiii morts anne
d'autriche décide de confisquer la
région sport elle-même elle a besoin de
pouvoir amadouer le parlement de paris
qui est le seul qui a la possibilité de
casser le testament de louis xiii et
d'accorder à anne d'autriche les pleins
pouvoirs le 18 mai 643 l'habile anne
d'autriche obtient du parlement la
pleine autorité au conseil mais la
minorité du roi réveille la soif de
pouvoir des princes de sang qui
entendent jouer un rôle au sommet de
l'état au lieu de continuer à donner un
rôle important aux ministres qui étaient
les ministres de richelieu et de louis
xiii
elle veut être seule région alors pour
cela elle a besoin d'abord d'acheter la
paix avec les princes du son elle se
révèle très habile y en a qu elle roule
bien il suffit de faire des promesses de
l'époque j'ai de tenir ses promesses
après et se fait un gouvernement quelque
sorte trop serré complètement à sa
dévotion qui est dirigée dès le départ
par mazarin mazarin kg est quelqu'un qui
a été formé par richelieu en choisissant
jules mazarin comme principal ministre
en autriche affirme sa volonté de
poursuivre l'oeuvre politique de louis
xiii et de richelieu c'est le début
d'une longue collaboration dans un
accord si parfait que certains
historiens soupçonneront une relation
amoureuse entre les deux protagonistes
et c'était un homme qui a su gagner
la confiance d'anne d'autriche et c'est
ce qui explique pourquoi ce couple
ce couple peu suspect aux yeux des gens
pensaient vraiment même peut-être qu'il
y avait un mariage secret entre mazarin
et anne d'autriche
c'est ce couple qui a fait l'éducation
du roi une régence pour les nobles c'est
toujours une période où ils se disent
qu'il va y avoir des opportunités et des
autoroutes unité forte puisque louis
xiii et surtout richelieu les avait
exclues du pouvoir
donc ils pensaient que ce serait un
retour en force
or voilà que surprise la reine anne
d'autriche dont il pensait qu'elle leur
a été très favorable va continuer avec
mazarin à appliquer la politique de son
défunt mari et du détester cardinal de
richelieu donc en quelque sorte c'est
une très mauvaise surprise pour les
nobles
anne d'autriche permet aux anciens
adversaires de la couronne de rentrer
d'exil
ce geste de clémence très vite perçu
comme un signe de faiblesse attise les
intrigues autour du duc de vendôme
bâtard d'henri iv et de son fils le duc
de beaufort une conjuration des grands
qu'on appellera la cabale des importants
se met en place
ces derniers estiment avoir été spolié
par richelieu au profit de la maison
rivale de compter le complot est bien
vite éventé et la régente fait
emprisonner les conjurés la politique de
anne d'autriche et de base arabe
profitant de l'élan qui a été donné par
louis xiii et richelieu a été une
politique consistant à rompre la
domination qui était une domination très
forte qui exerçait les habsbourgs par
rapport à la france
afin de léguer à son fils un royaume
puissant et victorieux la région tu
décides poursuivre la guerre contre
l'espagne et donc contre son propre
frère philippe iv
on va essayer de faire reculer la
frontière du nord de la france la
frontière du nord elle passe sur le
fleuve la somme
elle est très près de paris et des
villes comme arras comme lens comme
lille sont des villes espagnoles et dans
les dernières années du règne de louis
xiii petit à petit il ya des batailles
qui sont pas tous deux gagné par la
france la france est en infériorité
militaire très marquée à l'égard de
l'espagne et mazarin et anne d'autriche
poursuivre cette politique
le cardinal mène une guerre ambitieuse
contre l'espagne l'autriche et la
bavière tout en préparant des
négociations concrétisée par les traités
de westphalie signé le 24 octobre 648
cette paix met un terme à la guerre de
trente ans qui oppose catholiques et
protestants depuis seize 118 elles
remodèlent l'europe et consacre
l'hégémonie de la france qui obtient les
trois évêchés de toul metz et verdun
ainsi que la haute alsace mais d'un
régenter de cardinal profite du déclin
de la maison de habsbourg pour prolonger
le conflit avec l'espagne jusqu'en 16
[Musique]
des 743 un fond de révolte gronde contre
mazarin cet italien qui a la confiance
de la reine et qui chuchote à l'oreille
du jeune louis xiv la pression fiscale
nécessaire au financement de la guerre
contre l'espagne et toof le royaume un
bras de fer s'engage donc entre la
régente et le parlement anne d'autriche
tente d'imposer ses et 10 ans lit de
justice
le parlement quant à lui réclame le
droit d'habeas corpus par l'abolition
des lettres de cachet ainsi que la
suppression des intendants qui entravent
le pouvoir de la noblesse dans les
provinces
donc elle est obligée là de composer et
évidemment les princes de la famille
royale qu'on a un peu roulé ou qu'on
oppose les uns aux autres le parlement
de paris auquel on a été obligé
d'accorder un pouvoir important
tout ça fait que elle n'est pas
complètement libre de ses mouvements
même si elle s'appelle la région donc à
ce moment là on est toujours dans la
révolte des seniors on est toujours dans
ceux de disputes autour du véritable
pouvoir le roi appuyé par le peuple qui
veut que le roi le protège des excès des
seigneurs et puis les seniors qui ont de
véritables armées avec eux et puis qui
ont des relais très important au
parlement de paris donc il ya plusieurs
épisodes dans la fronde est d'abord la
fronde des parlementaires en août 16
148,1 d'autriche et mazarin feignent de
céder aux revendications des
parlementaires tout en faisant arrêter
les meneurs l'émeute éclate et le
parlement prend le contrôle de la
capitale derrière le prince de conti le
cardinal de retz et le duc de beaufort
la situation s'envenime dans la nuit du
5 au 6 janvier 16 149 le jeune louis xiv
et sa mère se réfugie au château de
saint germain
mazarin déclaré ennemi du roi et de
l'état par les fondeurs tente alors de
reprendre paris avec l'aide de
mercenaires allemands la paix de saint
germain signé le 1er avril 16 149 met
fin au blocus de paris il ya cette
fronde des parlementaires
la guerre civile commence cette guerre
civile qu'on appelle la fronde qui est
beaucoup plus sanglante que le jeu entre
enfants qui est celui de la fronde
et pendant cette guerre civile et anne
d'autriche va admirablement manoeuvrer
c'est une révolte dont les historiens
ont beaucoup peiné à trouver le sens je
dirais que c'est la dernière le dernier
soubresaut de tout le royaume de france
puisqu'il est à une fronde des nobles
ils feront des parlementaires une
dernière réaction face à l'affirmation
de l'absolutisme cet absolutisme qui se
traduit par le fait que le roi et
l'exclusif détenteur de la souveraineté
et en exclu tous les autres tous ceux
qui auparavant avait vocation à
gouverner avec lui le royaume et qui une
dernière fois
essaye au fond de justifier ce partage
du pouvoir dont ils sont exclus
le 18 janvier 750 le cardinal tente
d'affirmer son autorité en faisant
arrêter les princes de condé et de
compte y est ainsi que le duc de
longueville une fronde des nobles se
dresse alors contre la couronne soulève
les provinces et cherche à s'allier avec
l'ennemi espagnol louis xiv
anne d'autriche et mazarin accompagne
alors l'armée royale pour reconquérir la
france l'habile régente voit là
l'opportunité de présenter le roi son
peuple et en même temps de l'instruire
en matière de stratégie militaire
la région ça servi à apprendre à louis
xiv le métier de roi
son comportement son habileté elle est
bien conseillée par lazard
mais c'est son habilité malgré un
caractère qui a un caractère très fort
elle ne supporte pas les eaux france qui
sont faites pouvoir royal temps en temps
c'est mazarin plus somptueux qui lui dit
il faut faire semblant de céder et puis
on n'en sera que plus fort après pour
gagner la bataille suivante
et tout ceci fait qu'elles préservent le
trône
[Musique]
les frondeurs contraignent mazarin à
l'exil dans la nuit du 6 au 7 février
ses 151 gaston d'orléans l'ambitieux
frère de louis xiii réclame alors la
réunion des états généraux le 7
septembre 651 louis xiv et déclarés
majeurs
le prince de condé estime que le jeune
roi est manipulé par anne d'autriche
il entre alors en rébellion et tente de
nouer des alliances avec philippe iv
d'espagne
cromwell et le duc de lorraine le choc
militaire et violent le 7 avril et 16
150 de la bataille de bléneau oppose le
prince de condé à l'armée royale
commandé par turenne lequel parvient à
éviter de justesse la capture du roi
alors que les espagnols s'empare de
gravelines en mai des émeutes éclatent à
paris exaltée par les mazarinades s'est
libéré injurieux contre le cardinal lors
de la bataille du faubourg-saint-antoine
les 1er et 2 juillet 752 condé et les
ligueurs parviennent à prendre la
capitale grâce au soutien de la grande
mademoiselle fille de gaston d'orléans
et cousine germaine de louis xiv qui
fait pointer les canons de la bastille
sur les troupes royales
[Musique]
la grande mademoiselle devrait s'appeler
dans l'histoire la grande malheureuse
parce que elle a toujours été déçu en
amour et c'est quelqu'un d'important
non pas tellement pour sa trace dans
l'histoire
mais pour ce qu'elle assure raconté elle
fait partie des grands mémorialistes de
la période elle a décrit tout ce qu'elle
a vécu la grande mademoiselle d'abord
était amoureuse de son cousin louis xiv
et puis mazarin été complètement effrayé
l'idée de cette union
là tout fait pour l'empêcher puis après
elle a été folle de passion pour le
prince de condé au moment de la fronde
et elle arrive à le faire libérer
parce que c'est une constante chez elle
elle aime des hommes qui ont maille à
partir avec le pouvoir
alors qu'elle est quand princesse du
sang elle est complètement intégrée au
pouvoir royal
c'est donc un épisode dramatique au
cours duquel anne d'autriche et mazarin
ont été à deux doigts de perdre le
pouvoir et le jeune louis xiv l'a vécu
très intensément et ça va marquer sa vie
durant sa relation avec son entourage et
surtout à la chose politique
ça va être une des raisons pour
lesquelles il va être si soucieux de ne
laisser personne s'imposer auprès de lui
pour quelque sorte
co diriger la france voire l'exclure
d'une partie de cette souveraineté dont
il a l'exclusivité aux sessions
[Applaudissements]
les français épuisés par les guerres
successives se ralliera le roi louis xiv
garant de la paix intérieure entre
triomphalement dans paris le 21 octobre
[Applaudissements]
cette guerre civile qui enflamme le
royaume entre 16 148 et 753 renforce
paradoxalement l'absolutisme qu'elle
combattait louis xiv n'oubliera pas de
punir les nobles qui l'ont trahi durant
cette révolte
il fera construire à l'extérieur de la
capitale frondeuse le château de
versailles où il va s'employer à
asservir la noblesse et à centraliser le
pouvoir royal
[Musique]
lorsque louis xiv va être en mesure
d'exercer le pouvoir personnel
il a vraiment en main absolument toutes
les cartes et des cartes extrêmement
forte
et ça il le doit à sa mère
peut-être
le couronnement de louis xiv c'est en 16
c'est au lendemain de la fin de la
fronde mazarin qui avait été exilé
rentrer à paris
ressaisis avec un d'autriche le pouvoir
et le jeune louis xiv qui est déjà
majeur puisque la majorité du roi c'est
13 ans révolus il est majeur
donc il faut maintenant le sacré pour
assurer sa pleine puissance et en
quelque sorte la sanction de la fin de
la fronde de la reprise du pouvoir à
l'échelon central par ce trio qui est
alors anne d'autriche mazarin et le
jeune louis xiv désormais roi sacré roi
intronisé à la plénitude de sa majesté
je sacre de louis xiv c'est une étape
très importante ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il va prendre le pouvoir personnel il
est trop jeune encore à ce moment là
mais le sacre fait de lui ce roi donc qu
est ce roi intermédiaire entre dieu et
sa confiance alors plus tard on
appellera ça l'absolutisme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la guerre a été officiellement déclarée
en 1635 2635 1659
c'est la guerre la guerre ouverte avec
des hauts et des bas des répits mais
c'est toujours la guerre avec l'espagne
et ça va donc se terminer en 1659 et
c'est à ce moment là que la politique de
l'autriche et de mazarin c'est de dire
pour mais maintenant on arrête les
compteurs la france a réussi l'exploit
de s'imposer face à l'espagne et mazarin
négocie donc la paix est évidemment
l'enjeu c'est de rétablir
malgré tout l'harmonie entre les deux
principales puissances du temps la
france gagne je dirais par épuisement de
l'adversaire mais la france n'est pas
belle à voir l exemple il ya toutes les
guerres si billy à la ruine de beaucoup
de régions et on peut pas continuer à
financer des guerres interminables dans
l'état dans lequel se trouve l'économie
française
donc on l'arrête on a marqué tous les
points qu'il fallait on battra pas les
espagnols par ko mais on arrive à si
vous voulez un jeu nul à ce moment là le
7 novembre 16 159 le traité des pyrénées
marque la fin de la guerre entre la
france et l'espagne
il est signé sur l'île des faisans au
milieu du fleuve bidassoa qui sépare les
deux royaumes
et on dit le meilleur gage de la
réconciliation c'est évidemment un
mariage espagnol alors on sait par
l'expérience de louis xiii et anne
d'autriche que ça ne règle pas tout mais
on se dit n'empêche il vaut mieux être
allié par la famille par les liens du
sang que ne pas avoir de liens du tout
et c'est pour ça que ce mariage à une
très très grosse importance politique
parce que c'est on clôt la période de
l'affrontement entre la france et
l'espagne
la paix entre la france et l'espagne est
donc scellé le 9 juin 16 160 par le
mariage de louis xiv et de marie thérèse
d'autriche fille de philippe iv et donc
nièce d'anne d'autriche
[Musique]
il
une fois encore le cardinal mazarin pour
qui la raison d'état prévost se révèle
être un habile négociateur il introduit
une clause pour le non-paiement d'une
dot énorme qu'il a demandé à l'espagne
et donc il sait qu'elle ne pourra pas la
payer et cette clause prévoit que l'on
pourra rebondir sur une possibilité pour
la france d'accéder à la couronne
d'espagne et louis xiv fera jouer ça
ultérieurement
il ne trouve pas auprès de marie thérèse
le même cerveau que celui de sa mère
c'est pas la même chose et donc
évidemment marie thérèse et et louis xiv
ont eu de bonnes relations mais elle
n'avait pas ce caractère historico
politique fondée sur les épreuves vécues
au moment de la fronde etc qui était qui
caractérisait les relations entre louis
xiv et sa mère
[Musique]
après la mort de mazarin le 9 mars 761
louis xiv ne nommera pas de principal
ministre mais prendra toujours conseil
auprès de sa mère je crois qu'il avait
une adoration une très très très
profonde révérence pour elle sur le plan
purement psychologique
louis xiv a été éduqué par sa mère par
son père
l'éducation de louis xiv a souvent été
présentée comme un modèle du genre parce
que anne d'autriche avait vraiment pris
à coeur
l'idée qu'elle devait faire un grand roi
pour la france donc elle a élevé son
fils avec l'aide permanente de mazarin
dans l'idée qu'il fallait qu'il soit un
roi puissant fort qu'ils tiennent tout
le temps la noblesse leçons de la fronde
et qu' ils soient en même temps aimé de
son peuple
grâce à l'intelligence politique d'anne
d'autriche qui a su préserver le pouvoir
et le prestige de la couronne y compris
contre sa propre famille des habsbourg
et avec l'aide son brillant ministre
jules mazarin l'absolutisme du roi
soleil va pouvoir s'exprimer pleinement
[Musique]